Hock, scheinlich hast du es aber selber gelesen und jetzt?
So, ich muss mal kurz die Vorschau richtig aufmachen. Irgendwie buggt das gerade.
Yes, excellent. Ich bin krank, ich kann Maxan-Streams
auch und weit Pepo-Happy, ja. Nice, so muss das sein.
Heals gut, man. Pepo-Happy.
Ich hoffe, du bist nicht krank, weil du Pepo-Pupu machen musst.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen, ich weiß nicht, warum ich immer noch diesen
kack Avira-Gramm drauf habe auf dem zweiten Rechner.
Gut, ich weiß, weil ich es damals installiert habe.
Verursacht das Ding gerade 7% CPU-Last und ich weiß nicht, warum.
Es braucht einfach, wahrscheinlich, Krypto-Miner eraktivated.
War das nicht so, dass in Avira jetzt ein Krypto-Miner drin ist?
Kack-Wait. Es war nicht Bitcoin, es war...
Was war es denn? Es war, glaube ich, nicht Bitcoin.
Oder doch? Ich weiß nicht.
Ich mache das jetzt aus. Ethereum, ja, kann sein.
Meine Avira-Inbox sagt ganz wichtig, ich muss da unbedingt reingucken.
Hast du Urlaub? Nein, habe ich nicht. Ich arbeite montags doch nie.
Welcome to new Avira-Inbox. Was ist das schon wieder für ein Shit?
Alter, kann mich mein Viren-Scanner einfach in die Rudel...
Ich deinstalliere das jetzt. Das wird jetzt einfach deinstalliert.
Fertig. Aus. Remove.
Wett mit dem Scheiß. Avira, uninstall.
Hoffentlich lässt es sich uninstallieren. Darf ich ein Video vorschlagen?
Ja, kannst du machen, aber wir gucken heute keine Videos.
Ups. Erstmal schön ins Mikrofon gehustet.
Zum Glück ist es nicht ansteckend.
Jetzt braucht Avira ein komplettes CPU-Kern fürs Updaten.
Alter, das wird immer beschissener.
Ich lasse es jetzt laufen. Also, Leute, passt mal auf.
Heute wird es richtig high IQ. Wir gucken uns Unrate an.
Weil der Chat schon mir seit drei Jahren erzählt,
Max, du musst dir unbedingt mal Unrate angucken.
Und ich habe es mir auch in der VM schon mal ganz kurz angeguckt.
Ich habe schon einen USB-Stick fertig.
Und ich wollte es heute eigentlich komplett mit euch machen von Anfang an.
Mache ich im Endeffekt auch. Aber ich habe keinen zweiten USB-Stick
und ich habe Angst, dass ich meine Trial-Period resettet,
wenn ich die gleichen USB-Stick nochmal formatiere.
Ach so, wo hast du das her?
In Galileo oder? Und wie viel ist das in Fußballfeldern?
Oder in Warzone-Installationen? Aber danke für den Sub, der Eichler.
Leute, ich brauche einen gescheiten USB-Stick.
Ich habe nur Müll. Ich habe nur Müll.
Sagt mir mal einen gescheiten USB-Stick.
Was für einen USB-Stick soll ich mir kaufen dafür?
Also, ich brauche generell ordentliche USB-Sticks.
Ich habe den letzten räudigen USB-Stick hier,
den letzten, den ich gefunden habe dafür.
Ich habe kaum noch USB-Sticks. Die Sache ist die,
ich verwende auch keine USB-Sticks mehr.
Ich nehme einfach SSDs mit SATA zu USB, total einfach.
Das Problem ist nur,
Unraid möchte unbedingt einen USB-Stick
mit weltweit UNIQ-Nummer für den Lizenz-Key.
Das heißt, ich muss einen USB-Stick nehmen.
Und ich habe wirklich den allerletzten USB-Stick
irgendwo rausgefischt, den ich gefunden habe.
Einen Sandisk, ne, Kingston, 16G USB 2.0 habe ich rausgefischt.
USB-Platten und sowas habe ich mehr als genug da,
aber das reicht ja alleine nicht.
Und ich sollte mir eh mal wieder ein paar USB-Sticks kaufen.
Einfach ein paar halbwegs gescheite USB-Sticks,
so ein Fünferpack USB-Sticks, die was taugen irgendwie,
weil das braucht man immer mal.
Ja, das Ding hier wird mega heiß, das soll angeblich nichts taugen.
Leute, sagt mir einen guten USB-Stick.
Wie macht man das mit Lizenz?
Das ist wohl irgendwie an die ID vom USB-Stick gebunden.
Hier, taugt der.
128G.
13 Euro, kauf mir das Ding jetzt einfach.
Ja, normalerweise, wie gesagt, USB-SATA,
aber gibt es halt gerade nicht.
So, Leute, soll ich euch mal die Hardware zeigen,
auf der wir das ausprobieren?
Guckt mal, ich habe extra für euch,
wir machen heute nichts in der VM, wir machen das heute wirklich mit echter
Hardware.
Ich habe meine alte XEON-D-Kiste wieder ausgebuddelt.
Alte XEON-D-Kiste ist alles übrigens nur vom feinsten Noctua-Lüfter.
Wahrscheinlich waren die Lüfter so teuer wie das Mainboard oder so.
Würdest du Android auf so einem Low-Power-Intel-Board laufen lassen?
Klar, warum nicht?
Ja, dann sag mir einen anderen gescheiten USB-Stick.
Ich brauche irgendeinen ordentlichen USB-Stick.
Was soll ich nehmen?
Socken-Leak.
Was?
Stimmt, Socken-Leak.
Tatsächlich.
Und C.
Großer C-Leak.
Daumen-Leak.
Ai, ai, ai, was hier mit alles geleakt wird.
Nee, heute war man nicht da, Kreisel-Krein-PvP.
Vielleicht heute Abend wieder.
So, also, das ist eine alte XEON-D-Kiste, die ich habe.
Das ist ein 8-Kern XEON-D, fragt mich nicht genau welcher.
Noctua-Lüfter, einfach nur, weil es geht.
Ein SAS-Controller on-Board, ein Wechselrahmen mit 2x 10TB USB.
2x 10TB HDD, USB, Schwachsinn.
Das Mainboard hat damals ungefähr 1000 Euro gekostet.
Das war mit 2x 10G-Anschlüssen und 8-Core-Sock, also da habe ich tatsächlich diesmal echt
Kohle für ausgegeben und das ist ziemlich gut, aber maßlos Auferkill.
Aber ich habe gedacht, für diesen Versuch buddeln wir das einfach mal wieder aus.
Ist das eine Next-Cloud-Alternative?
Nein.
Das ist hauptsächlich ein Storage-System, allerdings mit jede Menge Zeug dabei.
Man kann das wahrscheinlich am ehesten mit so einem Synology zum Selbstinstallieren vergleichen.
Was der Anwalt sieht, es geht.
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Können wir ausprobieren?
Wartet mal, das können wir tatsächlich ausprobieren.
Wo ist der Watt-Champ?
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich es hingeschmissen habe.
Mist, Leute, ich weiß nicht, wo ich es hingeschmissen habe.
Ich hatte hier so ein Messgerät, was man inline anschließt, aber ich grabele mal kurz
hier unter den Tisch, ob ich das hier irgendwo hingeschmissen habe.
Ich habe nämlich aufgeräumt und seitdem finde ich nichts mehr.
Wait, nee, hier ist nichts, hier ist nichts, okay, keine Ahnung.
So, der taugt oder wie?
Nice, kauf ich mir dann.
Ja, wo habe ich denn, wir gucken wirklich mal, ich glaube so 30 Watt oder so, Eidl,
wo habe ich mein Strommess zwischen Stecker hin?
Das kann nicht weit sein, ich habe letztens hier erst alles abgebaut.
Wo habe ich den hin?
Ich sehe ihn jetzt auch nicht, ich würde mich selbst mal interessieren, was das zieht.
Irgendwie Eidl, irgendwie 30 Watt Eidl oder so, das ist nicht der Stromsparendste.
Oder 20, 25, warte, Leute, ich muss mal kurz aufstehen und in der Kiste kramen.
Und alles gerade bei der Kiste.
Oh, hab ich...
Ich hab keine fucking PS3 gefunden, aber nicht den Zwischenstecker.
JNLP